games about to start oh this time oh
what a beautiful I like Gronkowski we
know Chris we've all read your grunk
erotica it's not erotica it's fan
fiction very sexy fanfiction Gene Fonda
Rita Moreno Sally Fields and Lily Tomlin
are an iconic and hilarious group of
friends in their new movie 80 for Brady
this award-winning team of actors
stunned the film's premiere in Palm
Springs where Fonda gave an update on
her health back in September the actress
and activist revealed her Non-Hodgkin's
lymphoma diagnosis sharing on Instagram
that thankfully it is a quote very
treatable cancer I mean age it does get
to you you know 85 I can feel it in my
body but I I don't feel old because I'm
not sick
that's what's important Fonda originally
shared the good news on her website
writing last week I was told by my
oncologist that my cancer is in
remission and I can discontinue chemo
I'm feeling so blessed so fortunate I
thank all of you who prayed and sent
good thoughts my way I'm confident that
it played a role in the good news
we're great to meet your beauty has no
expiration date Chris I didn't flirt he
did meanwhile talking to the red carpet
her co-stars shared their feelings on
their Career Success and longevity in
the industry the only thing that you can
say about having a career that has a
duration to it is that you have it has
to just only be about the work wherever
you can find it whatever
just matters to you to to do and and
however big or small the role is however
big or small the project is I think just
the desire to work
and um well you know I think being in
Show Business uh gives people a a kind
of a leg up on on their health my career
was like okay
up until uh two years ago maybe a year
and I have a movie come out with with
Vin Diesel soon and I have this
wonderful movie with these four
astonishing ladies isn't that what
friendship is that we Face the unknown
together let's go Golden Girls come with
me
foreign